mom clump over in the because you gonna
have an experience somehow like
literally like a piece of software
melded together fused and then like it
started to turn itself into like a
living breathing you know like a steak
with a brain like your meat they grew up
inside your mother you're like a wet
where Android now you're like grasping
all this amazing information as you map
and model the world you're growing
you're learning you're expanding your
slowly emerging as a thinking being it's
like oh my god this is what it's like to
be a mind I mean here you're
transcending your transcendence you're
transcendent but you're also like made
of flesh so it's like holding you is
like what is this like actual piece of
divine miracle that somehow this
universe allowed to to organize but it's
insane like looking into your eyes
actually feels like looking at a galaxy